THE STATE OF IBM:
Once upon a time, IBM was a household name.
They were the most well known computer manufacturer
in the world period.
But, today, while people still recognize the
name, virtually no one buys computers from
IBM.
In fact, you can’t buy an IBM computer today
even if you wanted given that they sold the
business to Lenovo nearly 20 years ago.
This is quite surprising given that by all
accounts, IBM was very much a first mover
within the PC industry.
They launched their first PC way back in 1981
and I mean the company’s name itself is
International Business Machine.
Yet, by the late 1980s, IBM was rapidly losing
marketshare to newcomers like Dell and Compaq.
Heck, even the operating system that they
funded had turned into Microsoft.
This downtrend only got worse in the 1990s
as IBM would go onto post the worst quarter
in corporate history having lost $4.96 billion.
IBM’s market cap would halve in value while
the S&P 500 nearly doubled.
Fortunately for IBM, the dotcom bubble would
give them some room to breathe as investors
were lenient to say the least.
But, as the dotcom bubble collapsed in the
early 2000s, focus shifted back to IBM’s
underperformance within the PC market.
And this eventually led to IBM offloading
their most recognizable business.
Considering the situation, you would think
that IBM was headed towards bankruptcy or
at the very least a painful decline.
But, the exact opposite would actually take
place.
IBM’s revenue, earnings, and market cap
would all skyrocket.
And IBM would even overtake Microsoft for
a couple of years until Microsoft had their
own resurgence.
Today, IBM stands at a marketcap of a $133
billion which makes them the world’s 90th
largest company.
Clearly, losing within the PC industry hasn’t
killed off IBM altogether.
So, here’s the rise, fall, and resurrection
of one of the most iconic brands of all time.
FOUNDING IBM:
Taking a look back, the roots of IBM actually
date back to the 1800s to 4 different companies
which included the Bundy Manufacturing Company,
the Tabulating Machine Company, the International
Time Recording Company, and the Computing
Scale Company of America.
By far the most important of these was the
Tabulating Machine Company.
This company focused on creating data processing
machines for punch cards.
This proved to be relatively successful given
that it was a must have at manufacturing plants
and factories.
But the problem was that revenue from this
business was sporadic and unreliable.
I mean, how many times are prominent factories
going to need to buy punch card machines?
Maybe, once every few years if that.
So, the founder of the company, Herman Hollerith,
would shift his focus to a larger project,
the 1900 US census.
The census challenged his machines like never
before due to the raw volume and scale, but
Herman would successfully complete the project
which gave him some notoriety within the industry.
Despite this though, it didn’t take him
long to fall back to ground zero.
You see, the US only conducts a census once
every 10 years, so revenue became sporadic
and unreliable once again.
While Herman very much wanted to turn this
around, he was getting into his 50s and his
health wasn’t quite holding up.
So, he decided to sell the company to a man
named Charles Flint for $2.3 million.
Flint would combine this with a few other
businesses and create a new company called
CTR.
And very quickly, it became obvious that Flint
was no rookie at business.
He didn’t change anything technical about
the company.
Instead, he simply focused on expanding the
use cases and the sales force.
He would hire an executive named Thomas J
Watson, and Watson would basically become
the father of IBM.
The first thing that Watson did was hire a
bunch of salesmen and teach them the intricacies
of enterprise sales.
He instilled the values of company pride,
unbeatable customer service, and professionalism.
Watson also expanded the scope of the company
from just selling punch card machines to providing
corporations with large scale tabulating solutions.
This turned out to be extremely successful
and Watson would end up doubling the company’s
revenue within just 4 years of taking over.
Very soon, CTR would begin expanding internationally
to Europe, South America, Asia, and Australia.
Watson would also hone in on the companies
branding and public image.
One of his first branding efforts was creating
a company slogan, and for this, he would just
reuse a slogan that he thought at his last
job: THINK.
You might recognize this slogan today with
the Lenovo Thinkpad.
Anyway, Watson now had a company slogan, but
there was still something that was really
erking him.
Watson hated the name CTR.
He felt that it was clunky and confining,
so in 1924, he would change the name of the
company to IBM or International Business Machine.
It seems like this name change may have been
a bit unlucky though as the Great Depression
would role around not much later.
INDUSTRY LEADER:
The great depression would hit IBM hard.
Given that businesses were collapsing left
and right and given that IBM was a B2B business,
they had an extremely tough time keeping clients.
Nonetheless, Watson didn’t panic.
He was a strong believer in the idea that
if you had a great team that was building
useful products, demand would follow.
Watson would not only hire more employees
during the great depression, but he would
even increase their benefits.
IBM was one of the first companies to provide
group life insurance, survivor benefits, and
paid vacations.
But, despite Watson’s positive approach,
the effects of the great depression were very
much evident throughout IBM.
IBM was building up a massive inventory of
tabulating equipment with no market to sell
to.
But, as Watson was hoping, an opportunity
would eventually arise and it was massive.
In 1935, FDR would sign into effect the social
security act which required tabulating employment
records for 26 million people.
IBM was the only company that bid on this
contract and by the end of the depression,
IBM would evolve from being a mid size company
to being an industry leader.
And their dominance would only grow with the
onset of WW2 as IBM’s tabulating equipment
would prove instrumental in the war.
The allied forces widely used IBM’s equipment
for mobile record units, ballistics, accounting
and logistics, and of course punch cards.
To keep up with all this demand, IBM would
grow their manufacturing capacity exponentially,
opening factories all across the North East
and California.
Despite all this growth, Watson had a fear
in the back of his mind.
What would happen when the war came to an
end and government spending was cut substantially?
Watson began addressing this issue early on
to prepare as much as possible.
He increased IBM’s international presence
and played a major role in the formation of
the World Trade Corporation.
But, it turned out that none of this preparation
was even required.
As soon as WW2 came to an end, the US would
get knees deep into the Cold War.
The government no longer needed tabulating
equipment per se though.
What they wanted was a highly intelligent
machine also known as a computer, and this
is what got IBM into the PC game.
Unfortunately, Watson never got to see this
evolution as he would pass away in 1956, but
he very much laid the foundation for IBM’s
pivot into the PC market.
Just one year after Watson passed away, IBM
would introduce the programming language Fortran.
IBM would follow this up with a slew of computers
such as the IBM 1401 and the IBM 1403, but
the breakthrough didn’t happen till 1964
when they introduced the IBM system 360.
The feature that set apart this computer was
the fact that the hardware and software were
no longer bundled.
In other words, you could upgrade and swap
software.
This proved to be instrumental for NASA and
NASA would end up using IBM computers to land
the first humans on the moon in 1969.
This was no doubt the golden age for IBM,
but Watson’s fears from 25 years ago would
start coming to fruition as the government
heavily pulled back spending after winning
the space race.
PAINFUL FAILURE:
While the govenrment pulled back their contracts,
IBM was by no means in any distress.
Over the past 30 years, IBM had built an international
brand and had major companies as clients.
So, they were by no means going to die.
But, given that they had maxed out the corporate
and government side of things, IBM was forced
to look for new ways to grow and this led
to the public sector.
The only problem was that IBM had virtually
no experience selling to everyday consumers
and it would show.
IBM didn’t know it at the time though and
they would launch project SCAMP in 1973.
This project is what would eventually lead
to the introduction of IBM’s first personal
computer in 1981: the IBM 5150.
This computer actually turned out to be a
massive success because it made PCs relatively
affordable for the first time.
The 5150 launched for a price of $1,600.
And while that was by no means cheap as it
translates to $5200 today, it was way cheaper
than everything else on the market.
The Xerox Star, for example, came in at an
eyewatering $16,500.
Meanwhile, the Apple Macintosh came in at
$2,500, so for budget oriented customers,
which is most customers, the 5150 was the
top choice.
This would allow for IBM to dominate the market
throughout the early 1980s, but there was
just major problem.
People weren’t buying IBM computers because
there was some sort of unique feature to them
or because people loved the brand.
Rather, much of IBM’s popularity could be
explained by their price, and this is never
a good thing as it almost always leads in
a race to the bottom, and that’s exactly
what happened.
Dozens of new computer manufacturers like
Dell popped up, but there was one key difference
between manufacturers like IBM and manufacturers
like Dell.
The difference was that companies like Dell
weren’t computer manufacturers at all really,
they were computer assemblers.
They didn’t create new architectures or
put together software or any of that.
They just sourced the cheapest parts on the
market, installed MS Dos, and called it a
day.
This allowed them to undercut IBM by significant
margins.
The Dell Turbo for example costed a mere $795
which was half of IBM.
And given that IBM hadn’t built any brand
loyalty, people switched to these cheaper
computers in a heartbeat.
And the truth was that IBM simply couldn’t
compete at those prices.
They simply had far more overhead and R&D
expenses.
IBM didn’t want to call it quits either
though.
So, they just stuck around as their PC marketshare
waned year after year after year.
And, it wasn’t till after the dotcom bubble
that they would finally decide to pull the
plus and sell their PC business to Lenovo.
And that marked the end of IBM’s foray into
consumer products.
RESURRECTION:
While IBM had gotten destroyed in the consumer
PC market, their commercial business was still
doing alright.
So they decided to double down on commercial
customers, and this led them to a new goldmine
which was servers, databases, and of course
cloud computing.
Pretty soon, IBM was starting to turn things
around and it seemed like IBM was very much
resurrected.
But, it’s not all sunshines and rainbows
for IBM because their freedom within the cloud
market didn’t last all that long.
Since then, basically every company under
the sun has jumped onto the market whether
it be Apple, Google, Dell, Oracle, or Microsoft.
They all want a piece of the pie and this
has led to IBM shedding much of it’s cloud
gains.
In fact, IBM is very much in a downtrend once
again.
In the past 10 years, IBM’s revenue has
nearly halved from over $100 billion to barely
$60 billion.
A similar story can be seen with their net
income as well which has shrunk from over
$15 billion to just $1.2 billion.
It seems like investors are still giving IBM
a good amount of credit as they’ve been
able to maintain a pe ratio of over a 100.
But, if IBM continues to put up lackluster
performance, it’s not clear how much longer
investors will give them leeway, but that’s
just what I think.
Do you think IBM has a future?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re grateful for
IBM’s contributions.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.